[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
both men enter this match with tidal
waves of momentum which set them on a
collision course for this very moment
it's all or nothing and these two men
with
WWE
to get that blood flowin and the party
has officially begun
and one last thing these so-called
laid-back fans and Santa Clara are
anything but they're fired up here
tonight that's the first time tonight
we've seen that moves
seen it
what have you set me to do the win
tonight well we're going to find out
who's the better competitor that's for
sure no gimmicks here just some good
old-fashioned wool on action hobbits are
great athletes that's for sure but only
one of them can walk away them to win
and to be honest I don't know which one
it'll be
[Applause]
this kind of offense he's known for yeah
you're right about that he's made a name
for himself with this
when offense by AJ Styles
both men that elbow will knock you silly
[Applause]
rusev is known as the Bulgarian brute
his strength is superhuman like a
supervillain
it starts there through sense
athleticism means this 300-pound monster
moves like I can't I don't know if
anyone can stop rusev
[Applause]
the executed that maneuver they couldn't
find a home for that one well it
certainly wasn't due to a lack of trying
he's kicked into another gear here
tonight
the repetition on that move is becoming
deliberate at this point that's why it's
called high-risk ladies and gentlemen
check that out we have a first here this
evening and that was awesome Rousseff's
da mineira power and unbelievable
athleticism is only matched by 100s back
the Bulgarian brute rabid thirst to
destroy this man is trained in sumo and
Muay Thai as well as greco-roman
wrestling which means his ability to
punish his end s the right power speed
the desire for Destruction all of this
along with the ravishing Russian Lana
has resulted in some of the most
terrifying moments we've ever seen in
WWE
waleed out of harm's way smart strategy
there
back inside now
a j-style seems helpless he's on the
defensive here he looks to be a little
surprised right now let me get back to
this that
he's not as tough as I thought he was
and on top of that time these two guys
couldn't be any more evenly matched at
this point
I was building some well-deserved
momentum right now he is slowly getting
dissected
[Applause]
does he have his eyes open
it was over reverse that
we've seen in her tonight it must be
serious injuries no kidding that's going
to need some serious medical attention I
don't we've seen that woman before I
mean it's definitely a first tonight
this is great this guy'll try anything
[Applause]
he's on the defensive now yeah my god
his body's been through hell and his
ribs have bore the brunt of the attack
and I hope we can get a doctor out here
as a precaution damaged ribs like that
can make it hard to breathe he's making
a statement here with this attack
nice game moves I think it is a plan to
win around here and fast and that's why
the adage holds true there's a first
time for everything I think you're right
I believe that stuff
he disliked that this move is leading
the charge
[Applause]
sigh then I don't blame him nothing good
ever happens outside the ring
nobody home there nobody home
cold that look back that house has been
empty for months
[Applause]
he's in a world of trouble but 12
tonight damn he'll be able to continue
and I wouldn't be surprised if he had
nothing
here we go he's hanging on for dear life
[Applause]
one of these guys is going to walk away
with a win here tonight
here's your Twitter
Rousseff picks up the victory here night
about it not so many heads all of my
from hill I'm pretty sure I would have
made all
politics back sooner or later
match that was ladies and gentlemen
thanks for joining us
this will surely be a true mano-a-mano
test it's amazing for more than 50 years
men and women have entered this ring all
in the name of greatness to see you is
truly the best I think when it's all
said and done we'll be talking about
this match for a long time well these
head-to-head matchups you've got no one
to rely on but yourself and that's the
way it should be
it's go time people but no matter what
they say outside the ring it doesn't
matter as much as what happens inside
that ring
Fergus Tula rusev is thinking right now
I may not understand much of what rusev
says but I do go to the
in painful tonight tonight I've been
looking for this magic ever since I saw
it on the sketch you don't look at your
schedule yes I do and this one is a
calendar circular no doubt about it
he's starting to stumble here he's gonna
have to cut off his opponents offense
quickly and Michael this there's the
camel clutch
and somehow he's got to take the
pressure off his neck
[Applause]
rusev is known as the Bulgarian brute
history is locked up and made at the
party tap out
here is your winner
big win here tonight
absolutely whenever you get a win after
a match like this it's just big no
kidding I got to agree with you 100% ko
he should be really
there's few things more humiliating than
tap it out to your heart
there's no denying that the santa clara
crowd is nearly like what they just saw
well gentlemen this is it the moment
we've been waiting for the time for talk
to this behind us now these two
superstars to test one another's
like never before this isn't being the
best the two ties seen all the trash
talking on social media lately let's
just say some things were set there that
well could make a sailor blush party jab
you know it's nights like this that
keeps me coming back
that leaf from Oberon
hey guys I have to talk a little bit
about you set here we're going to find
out a lot here tonight head-to-head no
excuses let's get it on the title is not
on the line but if he can beat the
champion that'll go a long way to
bumping him up in the rankings here in
the WWE
rusev has found an answer here
he's starting to show signs of fatigue
he still got plenty of gas left in his
tank now
come on if he can't withstand this he's
in the wrong profession I think a lot of
people would agree with that assessment
John we're this safe I hope there's a
lot more left in the tank
Rousseff is known as the Bulgarian brute
his strength is superhuman
like a super villain there's the
submission hold he's in the driver's
seat now
[Applause]
Bank and he fights out of it he breaks
the hold not the first time we seen this
move time
AJ Styles on a good page down
what's an AJ style fight any differently
at this stage to stay in this thing
he'll need to find a way to turn
his guys have been so tightly matched up
until now but this might be world that
finally starts to change who sits da
mineira pounder and unbelievable
athleticism is only matched by
garyun rates landed first to destroy
this man is trained in sumo anytime as
well as greco-roman wrestling which
means his ability to punish his
endlessly ripe power speed the desire
for destruction all of this along with
the ravishing Russian Lana has resulted
in some of us moments we've ever seen
the dummy to be here we go
rusev can't be enjoying this
[Applause]
adding insult to potential injury damn
your eyes water
nice move
buh-bye there's no ways going to be able
to stand after that and that would hurt
his hand when he gets going like this
there are few better going to the well
again he's just playing classic offense
here yeah that's when is the most
dangerous rousseff showing a lot of
heart here but how can he turn this
around in his favor
I'd say he's starting to feel the
pressure a bit what's of the problem is
that he went to his finisher way too
early I don't know they seem to be a
winner yet in this one what he's still
not
I don't think so AJ Styles continues bad
games get out smart just about anyone
cold out of the way of that one
[Applause]
in testing Sir Isaac Newton's universal
law of gravity with that move that move
did it now this is God
point of insults have gone right to
humiliation that's right
that was a wild strike I'm missing the
target yeah look like
I've never seen him do that before
[Applause]
we'll be Victoria Handl shutters up now
that's a kick out nice
you know it's hard to believe but it
looks like peach still has some gas left
in his tank
[Applause]
another great night of action here
tonight as WWE comes to you from the
great city of Santa Clara
[Applause]
it looks like he's in no-man's land here
he needs to be able to put things back
together here Michael this is a
dangerous position to be in
he needs to be able to find a way to
clear the cobwebs and regroup
[Applause]
just making his presence felt there
expanding the repertoire with that my
god his body's been through hell in
Israel
[Applause]
[Music]
perk up he's gonna put this bit root
seven just so talented
this match has gone his way incredible
powers out
[Applause]
Ruth said showing his skills
stops the cow boy he is really tired now
that tank of his has to be reading empty
it has to be king but I still don't see
him giving up
[Applause]
tonight something new
that's the first time tonight we've seen
that move I wouldn't mind seen it a
little more often
Rousseff done some good work here
it's his way
designing on the fans off their feet
[Applause]
ah spy has to be broken right now
[Applause]
he may be in the best physical condition
I've ever seen him in
look at this man he's all business he's
off with the pan
referee's three-count after the amount
of punishment he's suffered it's simply
amazing that he's still in this one
though things could get real interesting
out here it's always interesting when
they battle outside the ring AJ Styles
hits the mat hard he's not going to like
that
[Applause]
back into the ring now
good lord that wasn't even close so
that's what it's like being so far off
the mark
he's begging for it
[Applause]
DJ style second
[Applause]
this is
insane does this building have a curfew
I feel like we might be here
night war a beating he thinks he has it
to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here is your winner the